real okay Rainier Maria okay is a German
poet who figures importantly in sort of
the middle period of existentialism he
also wrote One novel over the course of
his lifetime and that's what we're going
to look at today the notebooks of Malta
laureates Brigham
and there's a lot of interesting themes
that come up within real case poetry
over and over again surfacing
in this novel and it's it's also
a good lens through which to look at the
Poetry so that's why I'm actually
beginning with this first and then we'll
look at letters to a young poet and then
we'll finally get into the Poetry as
such
and there's certain key themes of the
novel that are going to keep arising
over and over again and again run
throughout the whole of real case life
and work writing itself the the function
of the in this case novelist or the
journalist also the function of the poet
himself or herself
existence what is it to to exist what is
it to be in the world what is it to
exist among other people within an
environment
what he calls things with a capital T
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more the emotions real K is is somebody
who's very good at depicting
oftentimes with just a word or two the
play of emotions within a person or even
within a thing within a situation
and we'll look at that in a bit more
detail later what I would like to say is
real K is is definitely somebody who has
experienced a wide variety of emotions
himself
childhood and adulthood
again themes that are very common in his
poetry a lot of his his poetry is
retrospective looking back to either his
childhood or somebody else's childhood
and sometimes an imagined one death
what it is to die what it is for other
people to die what death itself is
whether we ought to fear it or embrace
it that's going to be a key theme
time itself time understood both in
terms of the succession the passing of
time and also in terms of epochs of you
know the age that we're in is the Modern
Age fundamentally different from the
ages before it and is there value to be
found at each moment or it is value only
arise within certain cultural historical
situations
uh and then finally one other really
central theme love
and you might say well that fits in with
emotions but but love is dealt with in a
somewhat different way by by rilka
there is one other theme that I didn't
put on the board that I perhaps probably
should
um
runs through all of these
and Roca has a very ambiguous relation
to this this other key theme and that
would be in fact
God
real gay is a religious poet
deeply imbued with a sense of the Sacred
not only in its presence but also in its
loss
and in a very idiosyncratic way
he'll talk a little bit about religion
and about God he'll talk actually more
about God than religion in these
notebooks and also in his poetry
um you get a very profound sense of
rootedness of him trying to come to
grips with with uh
the god of his childhood the God that he
would like to find out there but in a
very
non-dogmatic it's committed
but not committed in the sense of
committed to a particular view on on God
or religion God is something that you
quest for for real king not something
that you say that you've you've got a
hold of you
can
necessarily transmit to others
so these are some key themes I'd like to
begin by
um
just mentioning or reading a few of the
central passages that help you get an
idea of what real case up to in this and
also in his other writings
and I'm actually going to be doing a lot
of reading from from real case novel in
this with maybe not as much commentary
as I usually give during these lectures
so because in his his writing is so
beautiful
so he says
this he's talking about his own writing
his own poetry
and this is this is a a fictional
character but this is also also real
king he says
I sit here in my little room I briga
whom 28 years old and completely unknown
I sit here and have nothing
and yet this nothing begins to think and
thinks five flights up on a gray Paris
afternoon these thoughts
now before I read these thoughts
I would like just to mention this what
this reminds me of more than anything
else is a passage by Blaise Pascal where
he talks about man as a thinking read as
there's nothing that thinks Pascal is
thinking in these terms as well and it's
not for for nothing that that Pascal is
often viewed as being an existentialist
before the movement of existentialism I
think real care is attuned to something
very much like that so
I'm nobody I'm nothing and yet I'm going
to think
what are the thoughts here's the
thoughts
is it possible it thinks that we have
not yet seen known or said anything real
and important
is it possible that we've had thousands
of years to look meditate and record and
that we have led these thousands of
years slip away like a recess at school
when there is just enough time to eat
your sandwich in an apple yes it's
possible
is it possible that despite our
discoveries and advances despite our
culture religion and science we have
remained on the surface of life
possible that even this surface which
might have been something has been
covered with an incredibly tedious
material which makes it look like the
living room furniture during the summer
vacation
yes it's possible
so let me pause right there at this
point we're dealing with stuff that
seems you know like fairly typical
adolescents my time is the time that you
know is going to break through and I'm
going to you know finally unveil
existence as it is everybody else has
been missing out so far is that is that
all there is though
is it possible that the whole history of
the world has been misunderstood is it
possible that the past is false because
we've always spoken about its masses
just as if we were telling about a
gathering of many people instead of
talking about the one person they were
standing around because he was a
stranger and was dying
now
we're starting to see some historical
depth
the question is
what should we be paying attention to
is it just whatever many people are
looking to or what the many people are
preoccupied with or is it the thing that
actually gives them some some Focus the
person who gives them some Focus
is it possible that we had thought to
retrieve what happened before we were
born is it possible that every one of us
would have to be reminded that he had
his origin and all who have gone before
that consequently he contains this past
and has nothing to learn from those who
assert their knowledge is greater yes it
is possible
is it possible that all these people
know with perfect accuracy a past that
never existed
is it possible that all realities are
nothing to them that their life is
running down unconnected with anything
like a clock in an empty room
yes it is possible
is it possible that we know nothing
about young girls who are nevertheless
living is it possible that we say women
children boys
not suspecting despite all our culture
not suspecting that these words have
long since had no plural but only
countless singulars yes it is possible
we're getting further and further
into a deep metaphysics here
we use these words to make sense out of
the environment that we're in
but existence is always singular is
always particular is always personal
we can speak of women children men
you'll talk about this in one of his
poems later on
but really there's only the singular
ones
and we try to group them together into
categories and then we think about those
abstract Concepts but really what we're
encountering are this man this child
this woman at this time
that's what has value
now he says is it possible that there
are people who say God and think that
this is something they have in common
take a couple of school ones one buys a
pocket knife and the same day his friend
buys another exactly like it after a
week they compare knives and it turns
out that there's now just a very distant
resemblance between them so differently
have they developed in different hands
oh so is the mother of one you can't own
anything without wearing it out in a day
in the same way is it possible to
believe we could have a god without
using him
that's very interesting isn't it
our our notion of God
when people use this word
is it like a count word like man woman
child is it a concept word
or in order to be something that really
matters does it have to be an
experienced and mysterious
reality
and if God really exists and if God is
you know infinite
is my grasp on God going to resemble
your grasp on God should we pretend that
those are
exactly the same that these Concepts
that we have map onto each other and
that if I don't have the same concept as
you do or you don't have the same
concept as I do you know we don't have
the same as somebody else or some group
that we are misgrasping God
that's you know something worth thinking
about that that rilka is suggesting here
and
like a pocket knife
um or you know here's another example
I'm very hard on things as uh not only
my wife but many other people pointed
out to me in time you know here's a
wallet and originally this wallet looked
pretty much I'm willing to guess like
all the other wallets that it came with
and now it's got certain colorations
certain
scratches certain
wear patterns to it
um
wouldn't God be like that I mean people
become like that we wear upon each other
we
change each other in the process
um
well God would be like that as well if
you say the solemns and you understand
God through saying the psalter every day
and meditating on that you know actually
there's something in the salt or like
that the man who meditates on the uh the
the law of God day and night
that's the very first Psalm you know
discusses that him being like a tree
planted near running Waters as roots go
down deep below and
he always has water even when it gets
dried
um
isn't that very different than than a
sort of abstract concept of well God is
something over there started the
universe uh isn't that very different
than somebody who
practices seeing God in the face of of
the other person day after day after day
well that's something that rilka is
having a sort of intimate experience
with
he goes on
if all this is possible if it has even a
semblance of possibility then surely for
the sake of everything in the world
something must be done
so writing is actually a call to action
on his part it seems like you know
strange thing the writer is somebody
who's removing him or herself from
reality and then maybe copying it but
this is an intervention within reality
for this for the sake of everything in
the world something must be done the
first Comer the one who had these
alarming thoughts must begin to do some
of the things that have been neglected
even though he is just anyone certainly
not the most suitable person
since there's no one else
this young insignificant Foreigner
Brigham will have to sit down in his
room five flights out up and keep
writing day and night yes he will have
to write that is how it will end so you
know rilkas is really this is a very
interesting self-reflective Passage
he's not the most suitable person it's
never the most suitable person who's
placed in the position of doing anything
that matters is it I mean more rarely
um
those who become Saints
they you know tell you I this really
wasn't my my job or my destiny but I I
took it on because I was the only person
who could do it at the time and I'm not
really happy with the job that I did
with it but there you go and it's that
way with great philosophers it's that
way with words teachers it's that way
with great writers
um
something else about writing too
this is a little bit earlier he's
talking about poetry
and he says
and this goes for the writer as well
poems amount to so little when you write
them too early in your life
you ought to wait and gather sense and
sweetness for a whole lifetime but a
long one if possible and then at the
very end you might be able to write 10
good lines
her poems are not as people think simply
emotions one has emotions early enough
that
parenthetical comment there
are experiences
before I go on with this so what he's
saying is something in effect similar to
what Aristotle is saying in the nick of
McCain ethics when he says you know you
shouldn't teach ethics to kids who are
only 18 years old because they have all
these you know
emotions and they have a hard time
keeping those emotions themselves in
track and emotions aren't enough to go
on for ethics what you need is some
actual life experience and by that he
doesn't mean having experiences in the
sense of having done something or seen
something or something like that he
means having meditated upon it having
thought about it having brought the
experiences together and formed Concepts
about them
real care is actually saying something
very similar to that now I'm not saying
actually that Aristotle is right about
this or that rilka is necessarily right
about this either
but I'm saying that they are talking
about the same type of thing one in
terms of moral philosophy one in terms
of artistic production
um
so let's go on and see what he has to
say about this
for the sake of a single poem you must
see many cities
many people and things
you must understand animals
must feel how birds fly and know the
gestures which small flowers make when
they open them in the morning
you must be able to think back to
streets and unknown neighborhoods to
unexpected encounters and to partings
you had long seen coming to days of
childhood whose mystery is still
unexplained to parents whom you had to
hurt when they brought in a joy and you
didn't pick it up because it was a joy
meant for someone else
childhood illnesses that began so
strangely with so many profound and
difficult transformations to days and
quiet restrained rooms into mornings by
the sea to the Sea itself to Seas to
nights of travel that rushed along High
overhead and went flying with all the
stars and it is still not enough to be
able to think of all that
that's already a lot isn't it
isn't it we'll come back to that in a
moment
you must have memories of many nights of
Love Each one different from all the
others
memories of women screaming in labor and
of light pale sleeping girls who have
just given birth in our closing again
but you must also have been beside the
dying
must have sat beside the dead in the
room with the open window and the
scattered noises
and it is not yet enough to have
memories
you must be able to forget them when
they are many and you must have the
immense patience to wait until they
return
For The Memories themselves are not
important
only when they have changed into our
very blood into glands and gesture and
are nameless no longer to be
distinguished from ourselves
only then can it happen than in some
very rare hour
the first word of a poem arises in their
midst and goes forth from them
so
beautiful passage right and again you
know real K is a poet so he has his his
ways with words
what is he saying is necessary here to
do the kind of writing that will
generate
genuine real
Transcendent authentic poetry what's how
do we get to our end product over here
well
you do need a motion
oops there we go so
and you have to have the many
experiences
is that enough
well now he's not spelling everything
out for you here and I'm not going to
linger over every single passage of the
book like I am here but I think this is
a very important to work our way through
you ought to wait and gather sense and
sweetness for a whole lifetime in a long
one if possible so what else is needed
time
and you have to
generate these into memories
and then you have to
to forget them
and then they have to become part
of your
very being the fabric of Who You Are
right
so we have two vectors here
time has to turn
the many experiences the emotions into
memories then you have to forget them
long enough for them to become part of
you know the very fabric of your being
um
like it says the memories themselves are
not important only when they have
changed into our very broad into
glancing gesture and are nameless
then in the rare hour the first word of
the poem arises in their midst and goes
forthrough so all of this is important
and many experiences of all sorts of
types right many emotions of all sorts
of types
what is the precondition for this to
happen
who thinks
one of which you have control over and
one of which you don't have control over
now if you actually want to
have
if you want to see many cities many
people and things understand animals
feel how birds fly know the gesture
which small flowers make when they open
them in the morning all those sorts of
things and you don't necessarily have to
have those things right you could have
other things substituting for that as
well
you know what that reminds me of is the
scene in the Blade Runner actually where
Rutger Howard's character is describing
having seen you know fire ships off of
and I forget exactly the Moon that
they're they're engaging in in battle
over I think it's a wonderful sight you
actually have to have not only
experiences but you have to have
openness
you have to pay attention
you have to give something you have to
give
it's not enough till that time pass you
actually have to give time to these
things you can't see how a flower opens
unless you're actually coming back to it
day after day after day
you know take crocuses for example the
very first flowers of spring at least in
the midwest where I grew up
you plant them the the season before and
fall they're there in the entire winter
while it's there's still snow on the
ground the first crocuses start shooting
their their shoots up and then you see a
tiny little flash of color yellow or
white or blue or purple and then they're
the first ones to actually unfold
themselves
you actually have to stop and pay
attention to what's going on and look at
those and care about that and value
seeing those flowers in relation to all
the other things that are going on in
your life or you're going to miss it
and then after you miss the crocuses
then you'll miss the uh daffodils
and the hyacinths and the Tulips and you
know it keeps going on and on and on
what else do you need well like he says
you have to gather all these things to
yourself
only then can it happen that in some
very rare hour
something fortuitous has to happen
something has to occur some some
Liberation has to take place
you can't make poetry just by doing all
of this this is all necessary conditions
for it
there has to be some fortuitous coming
together of things that awakens those
memories and now gets you ready
so that's what we're okay thinks that
poetry is really about and is that what
is going on here yeah in a sense what
else is going on though he describes
this a little bit later on
um
when he's talking about the process of
writing as well
so he says
he has an experience he decided that in
similar cases he would go straight to
the facts
I noticed how simple they were and what
a relief as opposed to conjectures as if
I hadn't known that all our insights are
added on later that they are balance
sheets nothing more right afterward a
new page begins with a completely
different account and no total carried
forward
would help with the present case with a
few facts which it was Child's Play to
establish
um
she's writing and that's part of what's
going on in this this novel if you're
reading it for the first time it may be
a bit disconcerting until you start
seeing some of the common threads tying
together because he seems to be jumping
from one thing to another The Narrative
is not remaining constant it's not in in
a great you know
sequence you could actually take parts
of it and put them earlier and parts
them and put them later and it wouldn't
necessarily alter the work
in any major sense he's jumping through
time back to his childhood or actually
the childhood of the narrator he's
jumping backwards even further in time
you know talking about what this poet
was doing or this Portuguese nun or um
you know this this King
so what what's actually going on there
these are like balance sheets each one a
separate thing
um not necessarily having an organic
totality of a great poem
um
let's go on now to the next important
thing existence
like I said before he's
casting himself in a very pascalient
sense as a nothing but a nothing who
thinks who experiences
and what is he thinking about the
meaning of not necessarily the meaning
of life as such but the meaning of
things the meaning of persons the
meaning of experiences
he's not just recording them he's
delving into them he's reflecting on
them he's trying to bring out into some
sort of verbalization
what it is that these things mean what
they are in their their heart
he talks about the experience in Paris
is having changed him
and there's a nice passage where he
actually brings up another poet not that
far removed from him in time bold lair
he says um
I'm in Paris
people who hear this are glad most of
them Envy me they're right it is a great
City great and filled with strange
Temptations I for myself I must admit
that I have in a certain sense succumb
to them I don't think there's any other
way to express it I had succumbed to
these Temptations this has brought about
certain changes if not in my character
at least in my point of view and in any
case in my life an entirely different
conception of all things is developed in
me under these influences I've had
certain experiences that separate me
from other people
more than anything I have ever felt in
the past
I'm going to read that one that one line
again
um
I've had certain experiences that
separate me from other people more than
anything I've ever felt in the past a
different world a new world filled with
new meanings
for the moment I am finding it a bit
difficult because everything is too new
I am a beginner in my own life
so these Temptations they're not just
Temptations to go out and have a good
time you know try new liquors that you
haven't had before have love affairs or
you know find some you know weird thing
that you can get into that only you know
a great City like Paris or New York or
something like that could offer you
this has to do with the meaning of his
own life who is he what is his existence
about
and he says do you remember bold layers
incredible poem which is actually
translated as you know like a caring we
don't actually call it a Roadkill
um perhaps I understand it now except
for the last stanza he was in the right
what would he have done after that
happened to him it was his test to see
in this terrifying and apparently
repulsive object
because that's what the poem is about
it's about Roadkill
and what's going on and how the you know
the maggots are you know writhing around
in it bold layer is able to find beauty
in it
relkey finds metaphysics in it
the being that underlies all individual
beings there is no choice no refusal
do you think it was by chance that
flobera wrote a saint Julian Los pitale
this it seems to me is the test whether
you can bring yourself to lie beside a
leper and Mormon with the warmth of your
own heart such an action could only have
good results
but don't think I'm suffering from
disenchantment here
on the contrary
um
one of the common problems that you see
in the modern world and a lot of people
have written about this they call it the
age of disenchantment
as if modernity means stripping away all
the the you know previous Superstition
and fairy world and you know all this
childish nonsense that people were
having before and leaving us with a
world that's Stark cold absurd not
connected with our desires our wishes it
can't correspond to our heart to what it
is that we most deeply desire
that's the way a lot of existentialists
represent the reality isn't it that's
the way Sarge represents it and Camus
and other people like that
that's not the way that Wilke represents
it
the world is mysterious
but the world offers us a kind of
intimacy
that does correspond ultimately to some
of our
deepest desires he says
don't think I'm suffering from
disenchantment on the contrary I'm
sometimes astonished by how readily I've
given up everything I expected in
exchange for what is real
even when that is awful
so
that's what he's talking about when he's
referring to Boulder's poem about about
the the carrier the Roadkill
and then he said he goes on a little bit
further and he says my God if only
something of this could be shared but
what would it be then what would it be
no it is only at the price of solitude
so that's that's the fundamental
question for real king in this this work
we get to know existence we get to know
being itself
can we communicate can we actually share
it
with another being and not communicate
it just in the sense of talking about it
or writing about it but actually have
Community share it in the sense of
partaking in it together
is that a possibility for us so we're
going to see that as we as we go on and
I'm actually going to skip over some of
the other themes
I'm going to skip over his discussion of
things you know with a capital T I'm
actually going to skip over some of the
discussions that he has of the various
emotions
I'm actually going to jump far ahead
into one of the things that happens in
his childhood and and
um it has to do with with love and
reading
um
there's a long Passage
where he is recollecting
and I'll just read this and make a few
interjections here and there
he says
it became obvious to me I was never a
real reader
as a child I thought that reading was a
profession which would have to be taken
out at some future time when all the
professions came around one by one for
consideration
and this is you know very typical sort
of child view of things real case
metaphysics is imbued with a kind of
fantasy that childhood things have that
introduces a a kind of uh
uh on the spot platonism we'll call it
where
anything can become real Concepts
objects and they not only can become
real they can become personal they can
take on personal characteristics
emotions intentions
so the professions would come around one
by one for consideration to tell the
truth I didn't have a clear idea of when
that would be I believe that I would be
able to tell when life turned around as
it were and came only from the outs from
outside as it until then come from
inside I imagine it would become
intelligible and unambiguous and never
liable to misunderstanding and this is a
child's view of adult life isn't it that
somehow all this is going to like you
know clear up and the Mysterious stuff
will become
clear as day
not simple by any means on the contrary
very exacting intricate intricate and
difficult perhaps but always visible
childhood strangely unbounded world is
unconditionality and elusiveness would
then have been surmounted though of
course I didn't know how
in reality
that world kept increasing
closing together in all sides and the
more I looked outside the more I stirred
up what was inside me God knows where it
came from but probably it grew to its
utmost limits and then suddenly broke
off it was easy to observe that
grown-ups were hardly disturbed by it at
all they went around judging and doing
and if they ever got into difficulties
they blamed it that on external
circumstances
so very interesting but attention's on
childhood and what it means to mature
they said so I postponed reading along
with other such matters until the
beginning of these changes until my
world started to
I thought it would become very clear and
unambiguous and it actually got more
complicated
then I would act towards books as I
acted towards friends there would be
time for them a definite time that would
pass regularly and pleasantly just as
much of it as I felt like naturally
certain of them would be closer to me
than others
but this is not to say I would be
certain of not wasting half an hour over
them every once in a while when I might
have been enjoying a walk a conversation
the First Act of a play or an urgent
letter
but then a person's hair could get must
up and Tangled as if he'd been lying on
it that his ears could grow flaming red
in his hands felt as cold as metal that
the long candle beside him could burn
down right to the Candlestick all this
was thank God not within the realm of
possibility
and then he says I mentioned these
symptoms because I met I myself and
experienced them quite vividly during
the vacation at olsgaard when I saw
suddenly discovered reading
it became immediately obvious I didn't
know how
I of course be had begun my reading
before the future time I decided to it
um
so he begins to have experiences with
reading and you might say the bug
catches him
and I'm going to skip over a little bit
he starts talking about you know finding
new worlds within the books
um and that the books would break off a
piece of the world
he says before books came it was whole
and perhaps it would be again that way
afterward but how could I who didn't
know how to read cope with them all
there they stood even in the modest
library in such hopeless abundance and
solidarity I plunged from book to book
and fought through the pages like
someone who has to perform a task Beyond
his strength at that time I read
Schiller in bagason and goes on and on
and on
um in the later years it occasionally
happened I woke up at night and the
Stars stood out with such reality and
moved forward so meaningfully and I
couldn't understand how people managed
to miss such a
notice he's not talking about reading
there he's talking about again he's the
sort of experiences that you have to
have if you want to do something like
poetry
um
I had a similar feeling I think whenever
I looked up from the books and glanced
outside where the summer was
where Abalone was calling me it seemed
quite surprising to us that she had to
call him that I didn't even answer this
was in the midst of our happiest time
but since the fever had now taken hold
of me I obsessively clung to my reading
and hid self-important napsa from our
daily holidays
Abalone is a woman who is uh clearly
older than him and related to him in
some sort of way and with whom he
has or experiences love
and then he says my readers trance ended
one day as suddenly as it become as it
had begun and then we made each other
thoroughly angry for Abalone didn't
spare me any kind of ridicule or
condescension and when I met her in the
arbor she would declare she was reading
that sort of spite him
and then he starts talking about their
relationship
um
and now we start shifting to the theme
of of Love itself
at least you could read out loud
bookworms
this didn't sound very hostile at all
and so he started to read aloud and then
he starts reading about another person
Bettina
and
this is a person who's writing letters
letters about
her own love and so we're going to look
now at the theme of love
and after that we'll look at
um
death and then we'll talk once more as
we end about about love
so real gear rates quite a bit in here
about different women some of it is
through recollection and some of it is
through kind of speculation
and there's two characters that stand
out in particular one is the one we've
already mentioned Abalone and I'm going
to read a little bit more about her and
then we'll talk about this Bettina
character and then we'll talk about love
itself and the girls in the city so
um what do we know about this this first
character
he says it was in the year after his
mother's death that he first noticed her
she was always there
and
um
like he says all at once I asked myself
why is she there
each of us had a reason for being there
even if it wasn't always as obvious as
for example the utility of selfie ox but
why was she there for a short time
people used to say she needed a little
entertainment that was quickly forgotten
no one contributed anything to it and
she didn't give you the impression she
was entertained she had one good quality
she's saying and that means there were
times that she's saying
and so the first our relationship
consisted in her telling me stories
about when my mom was a girl she wanted
very much to convince me how Brave and
Youthful my mom had been
and so she's she's telling these stories
and then he says
I was curious to know why Abalone had
not gotten married she seemed relatively
old and it never occurred to me she
might still be able to
there just wasn't anyone
she answered simply
and as she said these words she became
truly beautiful
is she beautiful I asked myself
surprised
then I left home to go to the academy
for the noble men in an odious and
painful period of my life began but
there at sorrow when I stood at a window
apart from the others and they left me
in peace for a while I would look out of
the trees and in such moments and at
night the certainty grew in me that she
was beautiful and I began to write her
all those letters long ones and short
ones many Secret Letters in which I
thought I was talking about all scarred
and my unhappiness but as I can see now
they must really have been love letters
so this is important you know having the
experiences is not just a matter of
going around and looking at things it is
a matter of
learning one of one's emotions and one's
emotions quite often times come upon one
before one even realizes what's going on
then he says when summer vacation
finally came though at first it seemed
it never would it was as if by
pre-arrangement that we didn't meet in
the presence of the others
and then he says I will never forget how
you looked at me then how you wore your
look holding it up on your back tilted
face like something that could never be
and so
this goes on
in bits and pieces here and there let's
look also at this character Bettina
who's who's a character that they're
both talking about
and he says this strange patina created
space with all her letters a world of
vastly and large dimensions
she's generating poetry
she's generating poetry through not
trying to write poems but through
writing love letters
from the beginning she spread herself
out through everything as if she had
already passed Beyond her death
everywhere she deeply entered into
existence became part of it and whatever
happened to her had from all eternity
been contained in nature in it she
recognized herself and she attached
herself from it almost painfully
laboriously guessed herself back as if
out of the past conjured her herself
like a ghost and endured it
and then a little bit later he says
he's addressing her your love was equal
to everything how is it possible that
everyone isn't still telling of Your
Love
what has happened since then that is
more important what are they concerned
with
you yourself knew the value of your love
you said it aloud to your greatest poet
so that he would make it human for it
was still Elemental
but in writing to you he dissuaded
people from believing it
um
he goes on and he's talking about
love itself
and he says
fate loves to invent designs and
patterns it's difficulty lies and in
complexity but life itself is difficult
because of its Simplicity it has just a
few elements of a Grandeur we can never
fathom
the fact that woman in accordance with
their nature must make the same choice
in relation to man this is what calls
forth the Doom quality of all love
relationships Resolute and fateless like
an eternal being she stands beside the
one who is transformed the woman who
loves always surpasses the man she loves
because life is larger than fate her
self-surrender wants to be infinite this
is her happiness but the nameless
suffering of her love has always been
that she is required to limit this
self-surrender
a lot going on there
um and and real case is primarily
thinking of this in terms of you know
women and men having different roles but
I think that you can actually see
something very similar going on in in
both sides of the relationship it just
depends on who is actually doing the
loving
this will come clear as we look at the
the issue of The Prodigal Son a little
bit later
um
it says there's no other lament that has
ever been lamented by women the first
two letters of Eloise contain only this
Eloise writing to abelard
and the first 500 years and 500 years
later it rises from the letters of the
Portuguese nun it is as recognizable as
a bird call and he talks about this
coming up with with other women in in
other places as well he's got this
passage about the girls in the city
um
who go to the big city again this is
Paris
and he says
here we go
um
occasionally you do find young girls
in front of these
paintings
there are a lot of young girls in the
museums who have here or there left
their houses who never no longer keep
anything they find themselves in front
of these tapestries and forget
themselves for a while
um he says
the main thing is just to keep drawing
for that is the reason they left home
one day rather violently they come from
good families
but when they lift their arms as they
draw it appears that their dress isn't
buttoned in back or at least not
completely there's a few buttons they
couldn't reach
for the way the dress when the dress was
made no one had imagined they would
suddenly go away alone
unless you have a friend who's going to
bother with that
inevitably you sometimes wonder as you
draw whether it wouldn't have been
possible to stay home after all if only
you could have been religious sincerely
religious in tune with the others but it
seems so absurd to try doing that in
common
um and then she he goes along a little
bit further in their intense absorption
within their work these young girls no
longer even think of looking up
they don't notice how in everything they
draw they are merely suppressing inside
themselves the unalterable life that in
these woven pictures is randomly open in
front of them infinite and unstable they
don't want to believe it now that so
much is changing they too want to change
they are on the verge of abandoning
themselves and thinking about themselves
as men might speak of them when they
aren't there this to them seems like
progress
there are already almost convinced that
you Search out One pleasure and then
another and then even a stronger one
that life consists in this you don't
want to stupidly lose it they've already
begun to look around and search they
whose strength always consisted in being
found
that comes Wilke says I think from their
tiredness
over their centuries they've taken onto
themselves the entire task of Love
they've played the entire dialogue both
parts
for man has only repeated their words
and done it badly this is relke's view
of Love up until
that it's primarily women who are
structuring all of this
um
despite that they've persevered day and
night and have increased in love and
misery and from among them under the
pressure of endless Sorrows those
powerful examples of women in love have
come forth who even as while they called
him surpassed the man they loved
who grew above him and Beyond him when
he didn't return like aspara stop or the
Portuguese nun who didn't cease until
though torment suddenly turned into a
bitter icy magnificence which nothing
could confuse
we know about these women because there
are letters that that have as if by a
miracle been preserved or books or poems
and he goes on there have been
innumerably more of them those who burn
their letters and others who no longer
have the strength to write them
um
and he talks about all these different
ways in which love
in the way that he's describing it as
something very powerful
conceals itself and Founders and loses
itself but really what he's describing
here is something very similar to poetry
poetry carried out in life
now he asks this this this thing and he
says
now that so much is changing isn't it
time for us to change couldn't we try to
gradually develop and slowly take upon
ourselves little by little our part in
the great task of love
we've been spared all its trouble and
that's why it is slipped in among our
distractions it's a piece of real lace
will sometimes fall into a child's toy
box
we have been spoiled by superficial
Pleasures like dilettants that are
looked upon as Masters
what if we despised our successes
what if we started from the very outset
to learn the task of love
which has always been done for us
what if we went ahead and became
beginners
now that much is changing
and that is really
what the book
well it's one of the things
that the book is about
what is it to Love Is Love
greater than death
is love something that reveals to us
existence in a way that's not you know
sort of putting rose-colored glasses on
and pretending that things are you know
better than they are it's not a filter
uh
keeping reality from us
it's rather alas or an opening showing
us reality as it truly is
and so I'm not going to have the time
actually to talk about about death
itself
there is actually no actually I'll talk
about one thing he talks about
um
a modern view on death and an older view
on death
one impersonal one personal and how it
has to do with beauty and how it could
have to do with love so I will talk
about that but then I want to get to the
prodigal son and and bring this to a
good end
um
he talks about
places where people die in the modern
world and that they're not very
concerned with the death that they
get and that death is almost
manufactured for them he says
you come you find a life ready made you
just have to slip it on you leave when
you want to or when you're forced to
anyway no effort
you die as best you can you die the
death that belongs to the sickness that
you have for all sicknesses are well
known it's also known that the Fatal
endings belong to the sicknesses and not
to the people and the sick person has so
to speak nothing more to do
and so you get a death
um
but it's not really yours it's just sort
of a thing that gets offended to you
and then he says when I think back to my
home
things were different back then
you knew that you had your death inside
you as a fruit has its core
the children have a small one in them
and the grown-up's a large one the women
had it in their womb and the men in
their chest you had it and that gave you
a strange dignity and a quiet pride and
then he talks about his grandfather
about Christopher uh DET love briga
um
but he talks also about here we go when
I think about the others I've seen or
heard of it's always the same they had a
death of Their Own
those men who carried it in their armor
inside themselves like a prisoner those
women who grew very old and small and
then on an enormous bed as if on the
stage of a theater in front of the whole
family and the assembled servants and
dogs discreetly and what the greatest
dignity passed away the children too
even the very small ones didn't have any
child's death
they gathered themselves and died what
they already were and what they would
have become
and what a Melancholy Beauty this gave
to women when they were pregnant and
stood there with their slender hands
instinctively resting on their large
bellies in which there were two fruits
child and a death
didn't the dense almost nourishing smile
on their emptied faces come from their
sometimes feeling that both were growing
inside them so the idea is that within
life
we
are
attached enough
to it
that there's something
for us even in in our death
there's a meaning to it
an appropriateness to it
as opposed to the sort of modern world
in which everything is no longer
singular is personal it's all very
impersonal just fit things fitting into
a concept and you get the depth that
fits you just like something off the
rack and if it fits good if it doesn't
you know
that's just the way it is
let's look now at how he ends the book
the the story of The Prodigal Son and
he's reworking this this old
gospel story into something quite new he
says
it would be difficult to persuade me
that the story of the prodigal son is
not the legend of a man who didn't want
to be loved
when he was a child everyone in the
house loved him he grew up not knowing
it could be any other way and got used
to their tenderness when he was a child
but as a boy he tried to lay aside these
habits he wouldn't have been able to say
it but when he spent the whole day
roaming around outside and didn't even
want to have the dogs with him it was
because they too loved him because in
their eyes he could see observation and
sympathy expectation concern because in
their presence he couldn't do anything
without giving pleasure or pain but what
he wanted in those days was that
profound indifference of heart which
sometimes early in the morning in the
fields seized him with such Purity he
had to start running in order to have no
time or breath to be more than a
weightless moment in which the Morning
Becomes conscious of itself
so
you know there can be a sheltered
existence in which one feels as if one
is
lacking reality missing out on on
something that's there and so that is
what he thinks the prodigal son leaves
behind
The Secret of that life of his which had
never yet come into being spread out
before it
so he goes away
um
and then he says my God how much there
was then to leave behind and forget for
you really had to forget otherwise you
would betray yourself when they insisted
and skipping ahead a little bit
he says
it's useless for such a person to walk
up to the front steps of infinite
caution they will all be in the living
room and as soon as the door opens they
will all look his way
he remains in the dark wants to wait for
their questions but then comes the worst
taken by the hands lead them over to the
table and all of them as many as are
there Gather inquisitively in front of
the lamp they have the best of it you
stay in the shadows and on him alone
Falls along with the light all the shame
of having a face can he stay and conform
to this lying life of approximations
which they've assigned to him
can he Define himself between the
delicate truthfulness of his will and
the course deceit which corrupts it in
his own eyes no he will go away
for example while they're all busy
setting out his birthday table those
badly guest presents which once again
are supposed to make up for everything
he will go away forever
not until long afterward when he
realized how thoroughly he had decided
never to love in order not to put anyone
in the terrible position of being loved
love from realkay is not something that
you know just gets you
in trouble if you love somebody else and
they don't love you back it imposes
demands on the Beloved on the one who's
cared for
um
and he says he remembered this years
later and like other good intentions and
two it proved impossible for he had
loved again and again in his Solitude
each time squandering his whole nature
and an unspeakable fear for the freedom
of the other person
slowly he'd learn to let the Rays of his
emotions shine through into the Beloved
object instead of consuming the emotion
in her and he was pampered by the joy of
recognizing
though the more and more Tran through
the more and more transparent form of
the Beloved the expanses that she opened
to his infinite desire for possession
so
I'm going to skip on a little bit
further
um
he's unable to keep himself from loving
that's probably a good thing
and you when you love you have to seek
objects for you that's that's the nature
of love it has to become concrete and it
has to change reality and make it
Greater
um
he says
later on
this is the time which began with his
feeling as general and Anonymous as a
slowly recovering convalescent he didn't
love anything unless it could be said
that he loved existing
The Humble love that he felt for his
sheep fell for him was no burden like
sunlight falling through clouds
strangers saw him on the Acropolis and
perhaps for many years he was one of the
Shepherds in La Beau and saw petrified
time Outlast that Noble family which in
spite of all their conquests under the
holy numbers seven and three could not
overcome the Fatal 16 raid start on
their own coat of arms or should I
imagine him at the origin and goes on
you know further with this he says it
doesn't matter
I see more than him I see his whole
existence which was then beginning its
long love towards God
that silent work undertaken without
thought of ever reaching its goal for
though he had wanted to hold himself
back forever he was now once again
overcome by the growing urgency of his
heart love
needs to come out
and it will come out in all different
ways and it will Orient itself towards
all sorts of things
the question is what it will
oriented solve towards what shape it
will take what direction
and he says
at this time you hope to be answered his
whole being which during his long
Solitude had become prescient in
perturbable promised him that the one he
was now turning to would be capable of
loving with a penetrate penetrating
radiant love
but even while he longed to be loved and
so masterful away his emotion which had
grown accustomed to Great distances
realized how extremely remote God was
there were nights when he thought he
would be able to fling himself into
space towards God hours full of
disclosure when he felt strong enough to
dive back to Earth and pull it up with
him on the tidal wave of his heart
but you know he finds that this this uh
doesn't work for him and then he says
during those years the great
Transformations are taking place inside
of it love works upon a mercy and
modifies them
he almost forgot God of difficult
joyousness he became totally absorbed in
mastering what constituted his inner
life he didn't want to admit anything
for he had no doubt that in all this his
love existed and was growing
um now he says those who have told the
story try at this point to remind us of
the house as it was then
there only a short time has passed a
short period of counted time everyone in
the house knows exactly how much
he's coming back home the dogs have
grown old but they're still alive
all the daily tasks stop faces appear in
the window faces that have aged or grown
up and touchingly resemble how they used
to look
and in one old phase grown suddenly pale
recognition breaks through recognition
is it really just recognition
forgiveness
forgiveness of what
love my God it is love
he the one who was recognized had no
longer had no longer thought preoccupied
as he was that love could still exist
it is easy to understand how everything
that happened then only this has been
handed down to us his gesture the
incredible gesture which had never been
seen before the gesture of Supplication
with which he threw himself at their
feet imploring them not to love
dizzy with fright they made him stand up
embraced him
they interpret it as Outburst in their
own way forgiving him
it must have been an Indescribable
relief for him
that in spite of the desperate Clarity
of his posture they all misunderstood
him
what what he had been bothered by before
Those Who Loved but didn't fully
understand him
now we're loving again
and the misunderstanding is actually
productive it is expressive of
how they
they feel how they value him and it's
exactly what he needs
he was probably able to stay he's giving
us the post grip now to The Prodigal Son
for every day he recognize more clearly
that their love of which they were so
vain into which they secretly encouraged
each other had nothing to do with him
it had to do with themselves
he almost had a smile at their exertions
and it was obvious how little they could
have him in mind how could they know who
he was he was now terribly difficult to
love and he felt that only one would be
capable of it but he was not yet willing
so it ends on a sort of ambiguous note
um
beautiful reworking of the story of The
Prodigal Son
and
if we want to end here on this what we
can say is that for real kid life is is
extremely rich
calls forth our our Attention our
openness
if we want to try to make the most of it
that's what we have to do
and that love is similarly ambiguous
mysterious rich
revelatory of being revelatory of our
existence but it doesn't clarify all of
our all of our problems it just opens us
up to
what actually is it opens us up to a
deeper life but not necessarily a more
pleasurable life not necessarily a life
in which all of our questions are
answered but at least one in which all
of them can be asked